THIS IS NOW IN SESSION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDIN NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW MMHM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
CALDERON. ZERO CERVANTES CHAU
CHEN CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
LARA BIKE FONG VINCE FONG
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA THE BROADER
GARCIA GIPSON GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEAD LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN WHEN. DONALD ANDERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK-SILVA
RAMOS REYES LOOSE REBAJAS ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SEYARTO SMITH STONE
TAKING BELLA THERE IS THE
VALLAPUDUA VOEPEL WALDRON BOARD
WEBER WICKS WILSON WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR SO WE MET MAY PROCEED WITH
SESSION PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER. WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YASIR KHAN. IN MY MASTER. IN THE
NAME OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. HUMBLE US
THIS DAY OUR GUARD. THEN WE
MIGHT PAUSE AND RECOGNIZE WHO
YOU ARE WITHIN OUR LIVES. AND
REFLECT UPON THE BOUNTIFUL
BLESSINGS THAT YOU HAVE THAT YOU
BESTOW UPON US. FORGIVE US WHEN
WE HAVE FAILED TO BE A MEDIUM TO
YOU. BOTH IN WORD AND DEED
FORGIVE US WHEN WE HAVE NOT
HEARD THE CRY OF THE NEEDY
FORGIVE US OF GOD WHEN WE HAVE
NOT LOVED OUR NEIGHBORS AS
OURSELVES. AND FREE US FOR
JOYFUL OBEDIENCE TO YOU AND
SERVICE TO OTHERS I MEAN. YES
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
NICE. READY BEGIN. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AND ZERO FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
TRIMMER SACRAMENTO TUESDAY MARCH
TWENTY NINE TWENTY TWENTY TO THE
ASSEMBLY MET AT SEVEN AM THE
HONORABLE KELLY C. R. TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIXTY SEVEN TO
FOR PROVIDING SHE PLUCKS
REPORTER PROTESTS REFLECTIVITY
MOMENT READING ROLL CALL MS
REYES MOVES. AND MISTER FLORA
SECONDS. THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS
HAVE PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE. THERE ARE NONE. PROVING
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. M. IS REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SET SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WOULD HOLDEN
AND PATTERSON. TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WAR TO HAVE A
GUEST SEATED AT HIS DESK AND
HAVE A TALK REFERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY. AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW COMMITTEE. COMMITTEES
TO NOTICE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO NOTICE AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY TWO GRAY. AND
AB NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR THEIR HEARING
ON TUESDAY APRIL TWENTY SIX. TO
ALLOW THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE AB NINETEEN FORTY SALAS
AND AB SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN
WEBER FOR THEIR HEARING ON
WEDNESDAY APRIL TWENTY SEVEN.
AND TO ALLOW JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TO NOTICE AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
TWO SANTIAGO. AND AB TWENTY
EIGHTY WOULD TO FOR THEIR
HEARING ON THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY
EIGHT. FURTHER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW
THE UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEES COMMITTEE TO NOTICE
THE FOLLOWING BILLS. FOR THE
HEARING ON WEDNESDAY APRIL
TWENTY SEVEN. TO NOTICE AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY MINUTE
SEARCHING PENDING REFERRAL FROM
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
AND TO NOTICE AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT CHOI PENDING
REFERRAL FROM THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE. AB SIXTEEN SIXTEEN
PETRIE-NORRIS FROM THE REVENUE
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. AB SEVENTY
NINETEEN WARD FROM THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE BUT THEY ARE QUE
HAND FROM THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
AND- AB TWENTY SIX NINETY SIX OF
THE WATER GARCIA FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE. TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AND AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS I COULD HAVE ATTENTION.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUESTS
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY IN
THE GALLERY. JOINING US IN THE
GALLERY OUR GUESTS FROM THE
SPECIAL OLYMPICS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON LET'S
WELCOME THE CONTAGION FROM
SPECIAL OLYMPICS TO THE ASSEMBLY
GALLERY.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PROCEED
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 220-616-9017
ELEVEN WITH IMAGE NINETEEN OF
FOR THE MEMBERS TWO THOUSAND ONE
OF THE MEMBERS TWENTY THREE
THIRTY SIX OF THE MEN'S TWENTY
THREE FIFTY FIVE OF THE MEMBERS
TWENTY SIX OF THE SEVEN OF THE
MEMBERS EIGHTEEN OH SIX AT THE
MOMENT. TWENTY THREE NINETY TWO
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY WITH A
MEMBERS TWENTY SEVEN I WAS A BIT
MUCH TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX OF THE
MEMBERS TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR
WITH A MEMBER SIXTEEN NINETY ONE
OF THEM AT SEVENTY FORTY SIX OF
THE MINUTES NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT
WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY NINE OH
THREE WITH MEMBERS TWENTY TWO
SIXTY SIX OF THE MEMBERS TWENTY
THREE FIFTY NINE WITH A MEMBERS
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
MINUTES TWENTY TWENTY ONE WITH
HIM. TWENTY NINE WITH A MEMBERS
ONLY FOURTEEN WITH MEMBERS
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY ONE OF THE
MINUTES SIXTEEN OH EIGHT TWENTY
ONE SIXTY SEVEN TWENTY THREE
THIRTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
SIX NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE TWENTY
FOUR NINETY THREE TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN OF THE
MEMBERS TWENTY SIX SIXTY ONE
POINT SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT WITH
MEMBERS TWENTY FORTY SEVEN WITH
A MEMBERS TWENTY TWO NINETY FIVE
OF THE MEMBERS TWENTY SIX THIRTY
FIVE OF THE MEMBERS. EIGHTEEN
NINETY SIX OF THE MEMBERS TWENTY
SIXTY THREE MINUTES TWENTY SEVEN
OH FIVE THE MINUTES TWENTY TWO
FIFTY EIGHT WITH A MEMBER TWENTY
THREE NINETEEN OF THE MEMBERS
TWENTY FORTY WITH A MEMBERS
TWENTY THREE TO SIX MINUTES
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY EIGHT WITH A
MEMBERS TWENTY TO TEN WITH THEM
IT'S AN ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO
SEVEN WITH A MINUTES. THAT'S
DAVID. ALL BILLS. WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND- DEEMED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO. MOVED
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP AS
CALDERON SAYS ITEM. WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM SIXTY
TWO. THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO
. AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. THIS
IS FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. AND THE
CLERK WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
ONE WITH A MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON. MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION IS
CALDERON IS CALDERON ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- AMENDMENTS TO AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION AND REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CALDERON. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE I. SEVENTY MEMBERS ARE
DOCTOR. BILLS OUT TO PRINCETON
BACK ON FILE. MEMBERS MOVING
BACK TO GAS INTRODUCTIONS WE
HAVE SPECIAL GUESTS IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY. JOINING US IN THE
GALLERY OUR STUDENTS FROM ST
BERNARD DINO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S STUDENT LEADERSHIP
ADVISORY COUNCIL ON BEHALF OF
MAJORITY LEADER REYES LET'S
WELCOME THEM. TO THE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS BACK TO THE TOP OF THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE FILE
ITEMS FIFTY. THROUGH FIFTY FOUR
PASS AND RETAIN THAT BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE THIS IS
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY THREE BY MR
GABRIEL AND THE COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE NINETY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
AND ACTUALLY THE COURTS MR
GABRIEL YOU MAIL BUT- THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I AM PLEASED
TODAY 2% AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
THREE WHICH WILL STRENGTHEN THE
SARGENT SHRIVER CIVIL COUNCIL
ACT. THE DRIVER PROGRAM PROVIDES
LEGAL REPRESENTATION TO LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS IN HIGH
STAKES CIVIL MATTERS IMPACTING
BASIC HUMAN NEEDS SUCH AS CHILD
CUSTODY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
EVICTION PROCEEDINGS. AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY THREE BUILDS ON
PROGRESS BY HELPING TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR LEGAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDED UNDER THE SHRIVER
PROGRAM. UNFORTUNATELY LEGAL
SERVICES ORGANIZATIONS ARE
CURRENTLY UNABLE TO PROVIDE
REPRESENTATION TO UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE OF
CONDITIONS ATTACHED TO FEDERAL
FUNDING. THIS LEGISLATION HELP
ADDRESS THAT INJUSTICE BY
REQUIRING THESE ORGANIZATIONS
STORE FOR IMMIGRANTS FOR OUR
SERVICES ELSEWHERE WHEN THEY ARE
UNABLE TO PROVIDE THEM. MISTER
SPEAKER THIS BILL IS BASED IN
PART ON MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AS ONE OF THE FIRST
CASES I TALK AS AN ATTORNEY WHEN
I PASSED THE BAR WAS
REPRESENTING A WOMAN WHO IS A
VICTIM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AND
SHE HAPPENED TO BE UNDOCUMENTED
AND HER ABUSER WAS A CITIZEN NOW
WOULD BE ABLE TO SEE THE WAY IN
WHICH ARE UNDOCUMENTED
POPULATION IS PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE. CHECK REALLY NEED OF
SO MANY OTHER IMPORTANT SERVICES
THAT ARE LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE THIS BILL
WOULD MAKE SURE THAT THE MOST
AFFORDABLE CALIFORNIANS GET
THOSE SERVICES IN A MORE TIMELY
AND EFFICIENT MANNER WITHOUT
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
SEE NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THIS ITEM. THE
CARD CALL THE ROLL. IT IS OUT
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE THREE YEAH THANK
YOU.
THE CLERK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS OF OUR REGARD TO PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS FIFTY SIX
FIFTY SEVEN AND FIFTY EIGHT. WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE. AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY ONE BY MISTER KALRA
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA ACTUALLY
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT. MR CALLER
YOU MAY OPEN THE MORNING MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY ONE REQUIRE PUBLIC
TRANSIT PLAYERS TO NOTIFY
TRANSIT UNIONS OF THEIR
INTENTION TO PROCURE OR
DEPLOYING NEW TECHNOLOGIES ARE
PUBLIC TRANSIT SERVICES
INCLUDING AUTONOMOUS TRANSIT
VEHICLES AT LEAST ONE YEAR PRIOR
UPON NOTIFICATION THE TRANS
REPORT WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
BARGAIN WITH THE UNION OVER THE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE NEW TECHNOLOGY AS WELL AS
THE CREATION OF A TRANSITION OR
RETRAINING PLAN FOR AFFECTED
WORKERS. TO BE CLEAR NOTHING IN
THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT THE USE
OF OR PREVENT A TRANSIT AGENCY
FROM EXPLORING AUTONOMOUS
TECHNOLOGY INSTEAD AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY ONE RIGHTFULLY
RECOGNIZES THESE TECHNOLOGIES
OFTEN COME WITH IMPACTS ON THE
EXISTING WORKFORCE THAT SHOULD
BE REVIEWED. WHILE TRANSIT
AGENCY MAY SCORE COST SAVINGS IN
LABOR COSTS THE STATE MUST BE
VIGILANT ENSURING PUBLIC SAFETY
AND MAINTAINING AN ADEQUTE
WORKFORCE AS A FORMER MEMBER AND
CHAIR THE VTA BOARD OF DIRECTORS
AS WELL AS A FORMER MEMBER OF
THE CAPITAL QUARTER JOINT POWERS
AND CALTRAIN BOARDS I UNDERSTAND
THE CONSIDERATIONS TRANSIT
AGENCIES MUST TAKE. WITH THE
EXPORTERS ON HOW WE OFFER
TRANSIT THEREFORE I'M HAPPY TO
WORKING A CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE CAT CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION I BELIEVE WE CAN
FIND A RESOLUTION TO THEIR
CONCERNS ON TERMINOLOGY IN THE
BILL. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU MISTER KALRA
. SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. A COUPLE OF THE ROLE.
IT IS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES FORTY SIX NO
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN SIXTY ONE
WE'VE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
SIXTY TO PASS A RETAIN A FILE
ITEM SIXTY THREE. WE'RE FILE
ITEM SIXTY FOUR. ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA RELATIVE
TO STUDENT LOANS. MR MEDINA
EMAIL BUT THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AJ ARE TWENTY SIX
URGES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
RECONSIDER THE STUDENT LOAN
REPAYMENT PLAN FOR ALL STUDENT
LOANS TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
PERSONAL SAVINGS RATE. PERSONAL
SAVINGS RATE IS THE PERCENTAGE
OF DISPOSABLE INCOME THE PEOPLE
HAVE AFTER PAYING TAXES BILLS
AND GROCERIES. THE STUDENT LET
LOAN DEBT IN THE UNITED STATES
HAS INCREASED BY MORE THAN 1100%
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS. CURRENTLY
MORE THAN THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS BARBERS- A
HUNDRED AND FORTY BILLION IN
FEDERAL LOANS. THE INCREASING
COST OF HIGHER EDUCATION HAS
BEEN EVEN MORE BURDENSOME FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. 37% OF
HISPANIC BORROWERS DELAYED
GETTING MARRIED OR HAVING
CHILDREN DUE TO STUDENT DEBT.
AND ABOUT FORTY SIX A BLACK
STUDENT BORROWERS HAVE PUT OFF
BUYING A HOUSE DUE TO THEIR
STUDENT DEBT. AMONG BLACK
STUDENT BORROWERS ON INCOME
DRIVEN REPAYMENT PLAN 71% DO NOT
HAVE A SAVINGS ACCOUNT. A. J. R.
TWENTY SIX URGES THE SECRETARY
OF EDUCATION TO ESTABLISH AND
SUBMIT TO CONGRESS FOR APPROVAL
A MONTHLY STUDENT LOAN PAYMENT
PLAN FOR ALL STUDENT LOANS
CENTERED ON THE MONTHLY PERSONAL
SAVINGS RATE. AT ACID THE FIRST
VOTE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE AGE A.
R. WE ARE GOING TO OPEN THE
FIRST ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CORPORAL. OR CALL
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THERE ARE CLERK WILL CLOSE A
ROLL SIXTY CO AUTHORS ADDED THIS
IS NAY J. R. WE WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE FOR ME YES WE WOULD
TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON THE H.
A R. CLERK WILL OPEN THE- ADAM.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE- IT IS OUT OF
L. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL ANTI THE
VOTE. I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
BEFORE THEY EXIT THE GALLERY
LET'S SAY HI TO THE- CONTINGENT
FROM THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO
LEADERSHIP CALIFORNIA CLASS.
THIS IS THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
CLASS OF LEADERSHIP CALIFORNIA.
WELCOME THEM TO THE ASSEMBLY.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS RETAIN A
FILE I'M SIXTY FIVE THROUGH
SIXTY NINE. THIS BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY ONE BY MR PATTERSON.
COOKERY ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER-PATTERSON IMMACULATE ISSUED
FINANCIAL AID. MR PATTERSON YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- AND MEMBERS. THE BILL
BEFORE YOU IS AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
ONE THIS WOULD PROHIBIT ANY
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE. OF THAT
RECEIVE STATE FUNDING FROM
REDUCING SCHOLARSHIP FINANCIAL
AID TO STUDENTS WHO ARE CURRENT
OR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. THESE
ARE ALREADY. NUMEROUS CHALLENGES
THAT FACE OF THESE FOSTER YOUTH
AND FORMER FOSTER CARE YOUTH.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
PURSUING THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION
AND SCHOLARSHIP DISPLACEMENT
ONLY FURTHER COMPLICATES THE
MATTER AND MOVES OF FARTHER AWAY
FROM ACHIEVEMENT FOR THESE
NEEDY. STUDENTS MANY OF THE
STUDENTS DO LACK SUPPORT
FINANCIAL RESOURCES THAT
GUIDANCE- BUT MANY OF THEIR
PEERS RECEIVE SO IT IS ESSENTIAL%
THAT THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
MAXIMIZE THEIR POTENTIAL THROUGH
SCHOLARSHIPS. AND FINANCIAL AID
OBVIOUSLY THE RISING COST OF
HOUSING AND BOOKS AND
TRANSPORTATION ALL THE OTHER
COSTS RELATED TO UP HIGHER
EDUCATION IT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP. FOR REMOVING A
FINANCIAL BURDEN PLACED ON THESE
INDIVIDUALS AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
ONE WILL GIVE CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ACHIEVE A COLLEGE DEGREE WITHOUT%
HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO AFFORD ALL OF
THE OTHER REQUIREMENTS. OF THEM
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. MISTER
SPOCK. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE. ASKED FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
. CLIP OF THE ROCK. IT IS OUT OF
THE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CULTURAL TIE VOTE
I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS SEVENTY
ONE. THROUGH SEVENTY THREE.
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FOUR A. C. R. ONE TWENTY THREE
BY MISTER SEYARTO THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY KIRK ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEYARTO
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO CRIME
VICTIMS RIGHTS WEEK. MISTRESS
AIRTEL. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO BRING
BEFORE YOU TODAY ACR ONE TWENTY
THREE WHICH ESTABLISHES THE WEEK
OF APRIL TWENTY FOURTH THROUGH
APRIL THIRTIETH AS CRIME VICTIMS
RIGHTS WEEK IN CALIFORNIA. THIS
YEAR THE THEME IS RIGHT ACCESS
AND EQUITY FOR ALL VICTIMS. THIS
THEME HIGHLIGHTS THE IMPORTANCE
OF HELPING CRIME SURVIVORS FIND
THEIR JUSTICE BY ENFORCING
VICTIMS RIGHTS LISTENING TO AND
MAKING VICTIMS NEEDS AND WHICH
IS A PRIORITY. AND PROVIDING
VICTIMS WITH ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES AND SERVICES THEY CAN
HELP THEM HEAL. IT'S ABOUT
RESTORING POWER TO SURVIVORS WHO
OFTEN FEEL POWERLESS IN THE
AFTERMATH OF A SERIOUS CRIME.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN AN INNOVATOR
IN THE VICTIM'S RIGHTS MOVEMENT
FOR GENERATIONS ESTABLISHING THE
FIRST CRIME VICTIMS COMPENSATION
PROGRAM IN THE NATION IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE. OTHER
TRAILBLAZING EFFORTS INCLUDE THE
WOMEN'S ADVOCATES AND HAVEN
HOUSE IN PASADENA. WHICH
ESTABLISHED THE FIRST SHELTERS
FOR BATTERED WOMEN IN THE NATION
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX AND
MOTHERS AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY WITH
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A CHAPTER
IN SACRAMENTO. MOREOVER
CALIFORNIA HAS ENSURING VICTIMS
RIGHTS IN THE STATE CONSTITUTION
WITH THE PASSAGE OF PROP
EIGHTEEN IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE VICTIMS BILL OF RIGHTS AND
REAFFIRMED IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
THE PASSAGE OF PROP NINE KNOWN
AS MARSY'S LAW. CALIFORNIA'S
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM MUST
CONTINUE IN ITS EFFORTS TO
BETTER COORDINATE AND IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF SERVICES PROVIDED
TO VICTIMS AND WITNESSES.
OBSERVING CRIME VICTIMS WEEK
WILL PROMOTE AWARENESS VICTIMS
ISSUES WHILE ACKNOWLEDGING. THE
COMBINED EFFORTS OF CITIZENS THE
GOVERNMENT AND THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM TO IMPROVE VICTIM
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SENDING A MESSAGE TO
VICTIMS OF CRIME THAT THEY ARE
NOT ALONE. AND THEY HAVE SUPPORT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR SAY ARE TELL
. SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE RESOLUTION MR SAYRE TWO
WOULD YOU LIKE THE FIRST ROLE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS YES THANK
YOU FOR SHOWING UP FOR CO
AUTHORS CLICK OVER THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS TO ADD IS A
CO AUTHOR. ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ALL THEIR SIXTY SIX
CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX.
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL
READ WITH AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO WITH A
MINUTES BY ASEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. MISTER HARDBACK
ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY TWO WHICH WOULD ALLOW
CERTIFIEDOCEAN LIFEGUARDS TO
WORK IN PUBLIC SWIMMING POOLS
WHEN THERE'S A STAFFING
SHORTAGE. THESE MEMBERS REMOVE
REFERENCES TO AQUATIC
INSTRUCTION AND ADD LANGUAGE TO
ENSURE THAT THE ADDITIONAL PULL
SPECIFIC CROSSOVER TRAINING IS
PROVIDED BY PERSONAL CERTIFIED
BY NATIONAL TRAINING AGENCY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU MS BERNARDA WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE I. SEVENTY
MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR BILLS OUT TO
BRING HIM BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR. THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS
ON TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR
BEFORE WE VOTE WE WILL FIRST
TAKE UP FILE ITEMS ONE OH ONE
THROUGH ONE OH FOUR ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ADDING CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK
WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON
RELATIVE TO CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION MONTH ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THIS AREA RELATIVE TO
PARKINSON'S AWARENESS MONTH.
HOUSE RESOLUTION NINETY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL RELATIVE
TO EDUCATION AND SHARING DAY
CALIFORNIA AND HOUSE RESOLUTION
MODEL THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA RELATIVES OF A SAKE. CLERK
WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE THE- ADD
ON AS A CO AUTHOR ON THOSE
RESOLUTIONS. CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTIONS ON CONSENT. THIS IS
CO AUTHORS. ON THE RESOLUTIONS
ON CONSENT. CLARK WELL. CLOSER
ALL. THERE ARE SIXTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS ADDED. MOVING TO VOTE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITSELF THE
CITY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE NINETY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MASON ACKLEY THE CAL
WORKS. CARCLUB IN THE WRONG.
WHAT IS THAT ABOUT THIS IS THE
CONSENSUS. CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE AND
TELL YOU ABOUT IS SIXTY EIGHT.
NOES ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS ADOPTED. THE CLERK WILL READ
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDARSOME PEOPLE
TWENTY ONE THIRTY SEVEN I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY FIVE FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SUM APRIL
SEVENTEEN TWENTY SIX I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SYMBOL SEVENTEEN
THIRTY TWO I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SUM APRIL EIGHTEEN FIFTY TWO I
SIXTY EIGHT OH ZERO SUM APRIL
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SYMBOL EIGHTEEN
NINETY THREE I SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SUM IN NINETEEN OH SEVEN I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SUM UP OF
NINETEEN TWENTY SIX HI SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SUM APRIL NINETEEN
FORTY SIX SIZE SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE
FORTY FIVE. I SIX EIGHT NO ZERO
SUM. I SIXTY EIGHT THERE ARE
SOME TWENTY TWO SÜ. FIVE SIX
EIGHT NO ZERO BILL TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
THREE THIRTY TWO. I SIXTY EIGHT
KNOWS THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY ONE I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SUM WE WILL TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY THREE I SIX EIGHT
NINE ZERO ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY SIX. SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SOLUTION ONE SEVENTY ONE I SIXTY
EIGHT ZERO ASSEMBLY HOUSE
RESOLUTION NINETY EIGHT. I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO HOUSE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL THREE I SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY NINE
OH SIX I. SIXTY EIGHT NO SIR.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY SEVEN I. SIXTY EIGHT.
DOES ZERO. MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE
HAVE A COMMITTEE HEARING THIS
MORNING THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE. ON CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICIES WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE SESSIONS IN SWING SPACE.
RIMAL LEVIN HUNDRED THAT SEAT
JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICIES UPON
ADJOURNMENT. IN SWING SPACE ROOM. ELEVEN HUNDRED. IN THE ABSENCE
OF OBJECTION. THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
GREEN CARPET AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS WHERE AN ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
WHAT TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR.
SO HE SERVICES YELLOW THIS IS
SHOWN THAT THE MEDIA. JUST ONE.
SOUNDS. THIS MEANS. MEMBERS WE
ARE THE GERMANS. WHERE THE
GERMANS TO MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY. DR
WOULD. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR A GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO JOIN IN THE MEMORY
OF RETIRED HEALDSBURG POLICE
CHIEF KEVIN BURKE WHO PASSED
AWAY AT HIS HOME IN HEALDSBURG
TWO WEEKS AGO. KEVIN WAS FIFTY
FIVE. HIS DEATH SHOCKED MANY OF
US. THIS IS THE SECOND TIME IN A
FEW WEEKS OF ABIDJAN IN THE
MEMORY OF A FRIEND AND LEADER.
WITHIN CINEMA COUNTY. KEVIN WAS
BORN IN ST ALINA THE SON OF A
LONGTIME TEACHER. I GREW UP
THERE WITH HIS BROTHER AND
SISTER. THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE HE
WAS AN EXTENSIVE TRAVELER TAKING
TRIPS AROUND THE WORLD. HE WAS
AN OUTDOORSMAN HUNTER AND AN
ATHLETE. HE RECEIVED HIS
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN ECONOMICS
FROM WHITTIER COLLEGE A LAW
DEGREE FROM THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA'S A LOT BERKELEY'S
LAW SCHOOL A MASTER'S DEGREE
FROM JOHNS HOPKINS UNIVERSITY IN
PUBLIC SAFETY MANAGEMENT. HE
WORKED AS A PROSECUTOR IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND BEGAN HIS CAREER IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AS AN OFFICER
WITH THE LAPD IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX RESEARCH PROTECT YEARS. HE
RETURNED TO THE NORTH COAST AS A
POLICE CHIEF AND CITY MANAGER IN
LAKE PORT. BEFORE YOU CAN HILLS
BURKE SERVING AS OUR CHIEF. FROM
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN UNTIL
RETIREMENT LAST YEAR. KEVIN WAS
RECOGNIZED FOR SKILLFULLY
NAVIGATING HIS COMMUNITY THROUGH
FLOODS. WILDFIRES THE PANDEMIC
AND REVAMPING THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AFTER EFFORTS AFTER
THE CITY REVIEWED ITS PROCESSES
AND POLICIES IN LIGHT. OF THE
NATIONAL ATTENTION ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT POLICE PREFERRED
FORM AND INSTITUTIONAL RACISM.
IN TWENTY TWENTY KEVIN
INTRODUCED HIS PLAN TO PURSUE A
MAJOR POLICE DEPARTMENT
REORGANIZATION AND REALLOCATION
OF FUNDS IN ORDER TO CREATE A
COMMUNITY EQUITY TEAM. WITH A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
AND AN OFFICER. THE COMMUNITY
ORIENTED AND EQUITY OR CORE
POLICING TEAM WAS LAUNCHED IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
KEVIN ENTERED THE RACE FOR
CINEMA COUNTY SHERIFF AND WAS
pOFFICIALS BEFORE HE WITHDREW
UNEXPECTEDLY LEFT UNEXPECTEDLY
LAST MONTH CITING HEALTH HEALTH
CONCERNS. WHEN STATED HIT
STATING HIS REASONS FOR RUNNING
FOR SHERIFF HE SAID MY VISION IS
TO TAKE THAT ORGANIZATION TO THE
NEXT LEVEL. I THINK THEY'RE
GREAT SOME GREAT MEN AND WOMEN
WORKING THERE I THINK IT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO BE A REGIONAL
LEADER. IN TERMS OF BEST
PRACTICES. KEVIN WOULD HAVE BEEN
CINEMA COUNTIES FIRST. AND
PROBABLY ONLY STAY. STATE WIDE
OPEN THE GEISHA. IS A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE ORGANIZATION
PROTECT AND DEFEND DEDICATED TO
LGBT LGBTQ INCLUSION AND
REPRESENTATION IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND ALSO VOLUNTEERED
WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION. THE SUMMIT COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT WAS ASKED
TO TAKE OVER THE INVESTIGATION
OF HIS DEATH. THEIR SPOKESMAN
REPORTED THAT IT APPEARED KEVIN
HAD TAKEN HIS OWN LIFE. WHEN
SOMETHING THIS TRAGIC HAPPENS WE
ALL ASK OURSELVES. WHEN WE
MISSED SOMETHING. WELL WE
COULD'VE HELPED. THERE ARE
PEOPLE IN COMMUNITIES EVERYWHERE
. EXPERIENCE MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES AND SOME COMMITTEES
MORE THAN OTHERS. BUT IT'S A
REMINDER TO ME TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE CIRCUMSTANCES BE
THERE IS FRIENDS. AND POLICY
MAKERS TO BE MORE. THERE ARE
MANY RESOURCES IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO ADDRESS ANXIETY.
DEPRESSION AND SUICIDE
PREVENTION. THE NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION LIFELINE IS ONE EIGHT
HUNDRED. TWO SEVEN THREE EIGHT
TWO FIVE FIVE. AND ONE DEDICATED
TO L. G. B. T. Q. I. A. IS. ONE
EIGHT SIX SIX FOUR EIGHT EIGHT.
SEVEN THREE EIGHT SIX SO WE
DURING THE MEMORY OF KEVIN BURKE
. THANK YOU DOCTOR WHAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I RISE TO REQUEST THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
ELENA MATTHIAS. LEHMANN TIES
DIED ON MARCH FOURTH AT HER HOME
IN PASADENA AS SHE AND HER
HUSBAND DOUG FORD'S HELD HANDS
AND EXCHANGE FINAL I LOVE YOUS.
SHE WAS FIFTY YEARS OLD. WHEN I
WAS A RELIGION WAS RELENTLESS IN
HER DESIRE TO BETTER THE WORLD
AROUND HER AND PROTECT THE
VULNERABLE. AFTER THE
PREVENTABLE DEATH OF HER SIX
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER. SHE AND HER
HUSBAND DOUG FOUNDED A CAMPUS
SAFETY AND DROWNING PREVENTION
NONPROFIT THE MEOW MEOW
FOUNDATION. TO INSURE OTHER
PARENTS NEVER HAVE TO RELIVE
THEIR TRAGIC EXPERIENCE. LATER
EARNED A BA IN POLITICAL SCIENCE
FROM PROVIDENCE COLLEGE AND A
JURIS DOCTORATE FROM ST JOHN'S
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF LAW. SHE
WAS AN ACCOMPLISHED ATTORNEY AND
A TWO THOUSAND SIX ELENA BECAME
PRINCIPAL COUNSEL AT THE WALT
DISNEY COMPANY. ELENA ALSO OWNED
AND OPERATED A RETAIL ARTS
OPERATION WITH HER HUSBAND AND
VOLUNTEERED WITH PUBLIC COUNCIL
WHERE SHE REPRESENTED PARENTS
WHO ADOPTED CHILDREN LOS ANGELES
. BUT SOME OF HER FAVORITE
MOMENTS WERE VOLUNTEERING AT ST
REPEL SPANISH IMMERSION PUBLIC
SCHOOL WHERE SHE READ STORIES
FOR HER DAUGHTER ROXY AND HER
CLASSMATES. ELAINE IS SURVIVED
BY HER LOVING FAMILY FRIENDS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. ALEX I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
THE LOVING MOTHER AND WIFE ELENA
MATIZ. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN. AND
MR PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. I GET
MY MIKE TO BE ON PLACE. I HAVE A
RENTAL OKAY MY RACK AT A RED
LIGHT. WASN'T READ BEFORE. I CAN
HEAR SELL- THANK MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS OF MY MASKING- THAT YOU
JOIN WITH ME AND OTHERS IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA IN THE FRESNO
AREA JOINING IN MEMORY OF RANDY
ROCA. A THIRD GENERATION SON
MADE GROWER AND A FAMILY FRIEND
OF SHARON AND I. RANDY WAS A
LOVING FATHER HUSBAND HE WAS AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF OUR COMMUNITY
AND IN SO MANY WAYS. WAS GIVING
BACK. HE ATTENDED FRESNO STATE
UNIVERSITY WITH A DEGREE IN
VITICULTURE. AND JOIN THE FAMILY
FULL TIME UPON HIS GRADUATION.
HE WAS ACTIVE IN THE PRISON
MINISTRY OF THE BILL GLASS
PRISON MINISTRY EVENTUALLY
BECOMING ITS LEADER HE WAS A MAN
OF. DEEP AND HUMBLE FAITH AND HE
LIVED THAT FAITH OUT. IN FRONT
OF ALL OF US- EVERY SINGLE DAY
AND WE THANK HIM FOR IT. FOR
THAT VERY MUCH. IS LOVED IN THE
PHARMACY MUNITY AS WELL- AND HE
FELT THAT HIS. WORKING FARMING
WAS ACTUALLY SORT OF A LIFE TIME
CALLING AND HE LOVED THE BEAUTY
OF HIS FAMILY FARM AND HE WOULD
OFTEN- TAKE MARVELOUS OF
PHOTOGRAPHS OF- SUNRISES AND
SUNSETS OVER HIS VINEYARDS AND
HIS ORCHARDS. THERE WAS A SENSE
OF SPIRITUALITY IN HIS-
STEWARDSHIP OF THE LAND AND
GROWING THESE VINEYARDS AND
ORCHARDS IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
CHRISTY THEIR TO CHILDREN THAT
KTM TWO GRANDCHILDREN MAC AND
CHARLOTTE. RANDY WAS BELOVED IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND TAKEN FAR TOO
EARLY FROM US IN HIS EARLY
SIXTIES FROM HIS ABOUT WITH
CANCER. WE ARE IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA THIS WEEKEND WE WILL
CELEBRATE HIS LIFE WELL LIVED
BUT WE WILL ALSO MOURNED HIS
PASSING ALONG WITH BELOVED
FAMILY AND FRIENDS I ASK FOR YOU
TO JOIN US IN REMEMBERING THIS
WONDERFUL MAN HIS LIFE WELL
LIVED. AND WE ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN THIS BODY IN HIS BELOVED
MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
PATTERSON. MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAME SUGGESTS WE PRINT IN
THE JOURNAL ALL REQUEST WHICH
YOUR MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
FRIDAY APRIL TWENTY SECOND NO
FLOOR SESSION- CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY APRIL TWENTY FIFTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT ONE PM. ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
RETAIN A MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING A
FOR THE BUSINESS. I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
THIS CARILLO MOVES MISTER
PATTERSON SECOND SET THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
APRIL TWENTY FIFTH. AT ONE PM.
WE ARE ADJOURNED.